you know him best from the x-men films  but director Bryan Singer's next project  has nothing to do with Marvel's famous  mutants instead he's diving into a  remake of the classic fantasy movie  20,000 Leagues Under the Sea singer will  be directing his own script when  production begins this fall he initially  revealed the project on his 50th  birthday in a new statement he said ever  since I was a boy and first discovered  the 1870 Jules Verne novel I have dreamt  of retelling this classic story without  revealing too much it contains not only  the original characters of Captain Nemo  Ned land and professor Aaron axe but  also some new and original characters in  sci fi plot twists culminating in a  timeless adventure for all ages last  time we saw 20,000 Leagues on the big  screen was Disney's movie in 1954 so  this remake is a long time coming in the  meantime singers Xmen apocalypse is due  on May 27th of this year keep an eye on  gamespot for more news when that movie  drops  you